All right.
It's June 29th, 2026.
This is Active Inference Institute
Quarterly Roundtable number two in 2026.
This is Daniel Friedman.
Some short links that will follow as we
will soon discuss to an ever-developing
website.
Today in the quarterly roundtable, we'll
say hello and welcome. See if anyone
else will join.
Go over some institute updates. Go over
project level updates. Then check the
live chat.
To situate us within the year, we're in
the end of the second quarter.
We've been having these quarterly
roundtables since the beginning of 2021.
And second quarter is sort of our
midpoint. Take a
summer-ish
break in July.
And then head into the third and fourth
quarter of the year
where we look especially towards the
symposium and setting up and learning,
closing the loop for this year, opening
up to next year.
And as laid out earlier,
this year has been defined by a lot of
onboarding,
a lot of activity in the Nam Joshi
Fundamentals Textbook Group, and other
areas.
And bringing all these different pieces
and ideas together, working in different
ways,
that's the future of Active Inference.
All right. Start with our scientific
advisory board
who was helping us in various capacities
this quarter with reviewing
research fellow applications and also
the first renewals of the program
and several other ways.
Having ongoing discussions with our two
partner organizations,
First Principles First and Numenta
Games,
and having a lot of discussion in the
board of directors about partnerships
and variety of different programs,
updates,
ways that we're seeking to
develop and streamline our work.
We are exploring different ways to
support
different kinds of activities in the
ecosystem
as we learn from our early experiences
with project-level funding
like to the AICACP
and other updates that'll come in the
coming minutes.
And seeking how to use partnerships and
other philanthropic relationships to
support the kind of
work that various educational, research,
and admin roles could play.
Okay, first
institute project updates.
Along with Andrew Pachia and Fraser
Patterson
and many participants, we have been
active in the
Fundamentals of Active Inference
textbook group.
We have been meeting
two times a week
to do two weeks per chapter on so far
the first five chapters
of
book and have a Fundamentals
repo where there are some software
examples
and some related topics, simulations,
and things like that.
And it's been a great
learning experience first time going
through this book and uh
two weeks per chapter being both too
little
and a lot of time to explore the topics
and we're just heading into part two on
the core active inference
section.
We are just getting started in
organizing for the sixth applied active
inference symposium with a team.
And right now, we are looking for
presenters, sponsoring organizations,
and those who would be interested to
help in this kind of co-organizing
sprint
from basically
July
to November 12th and 13th.
And
we will be
reaching out more
uh sharing
newsletter
and YouTube updates when there's more
detail on themes and so on. So, for now,
if you're interested in some
streamlined ways to
present your work,
to
sponsor,
and support,
and to
be a co-organizer
for the symposium,
the short link will
have more information.
And
speaking of short links,
in the last few days, we have uploaded a
first public version of the new
activeinference.institute
site, which will definitely change as
things go.
It's a interesting site
as I hope will continue to be the case.
You can pick what I like color
you like.
You can select from
different
languages
or translate it some other way
yourself.
And there's a few other cool features of
this site.
Uh some of the information is still more
current as of right now in our Coda
living site.
We're definitely exploring and and
looking to have contribution around this
kind of
digital architecture
and how to connect up these different
pathways.
This is a release artifact GitHub page
site
from another
repository.
And
different ways to to find different
entry points, simulations, tools,
domain,
learning,
start, all these different kinds of
things that come up and have come up
over the
Okay.
We are
happy to share that in June 2026
the Survival and Flourishing Fund
awarded $200,000 grant to the Institute
to support work on the Common Grounds
project.
This project was led by Nick Hayes.
And Common Grounds in in the project
description, he described it as, "Common
Grounds is building rich virtual
playgrounds where AIs and humans can
share social and physical experiences
grounding language in embodied
interactions that mirror young
children's cognitive development."
So, congrats to Nick and looking forward
to this project.
The AI Capabilities and Alignment
Project AICACP
reported on a special issue of the
philosophical transactions.
World models in natural and artificial
intelligence.
And there's more information on slide.
The
theoretical neurobiology group
TNB group with Karl Friston has
continued to meet.
This
screenshot was
from today.
And so just every couple of days there
continue to be
cool
presentations
and work.
And you can kind of
step in and email the organizers and
join these.
Or watching them is also very
interesting.
This quarter in production was somewhat
light
with
three streams, interestingly all model
streams
on IMDP, the 1.0 release with Connor
Hines et al.
The online generalize online generalized
predictive coding
with
Baron
and formal verification of discrete
active inference systems
and
So,
interesting quarter with few streams.
And if someone's interested in
uh proposing some
series
of
streamer recorded content
it's something that we're definitely
open to.
Journal the journal utilities
repo
is a local for local first way to
interact with
the videos from the Institute channel or
if you configure it differently, a
different channel.
And
it will currently
allow you to get set up to the point of
asking
that knowledge base with LLM. [snorts]
And definitely there's some
uh
better ways it could be
hooked up to chat and to
knowledge systems.
Uh as models versioned,
I've kept updating [snorts]
things like the courses repo
where using combinatoric generation
you can
generate or
modify
a different kind of modular curriculum
for a given
length of course or extensive math or
programming backgrounds.
Fraser Patterson and several others have
continued to meet on the RXNFER
and I just checked that it's now RXNFER
version 5 with some breaking changes.
So.
Going into project updates,
here's our current set of research
fellows.
And these are individuals who are
affiliated with the Institute
and we look to scaffold their work
and
bring them
with feedback
with the scientific advisory board.
J.F. Cloutier in symbolic cognitive
robotics writes
information on the slide.
There's going to be a lot of updates for
the the following projects. So, I
believe
to keep the
verbal part short,
uh I will just
show the slide
and and move forward after not not
reading the whole slide, but there's
more information on the slide for all of
these. There's just going to be a lot of
them. So, I'm just going to show them
primarily.
Shigeru Robin
and Andrew Bashe published a new paper,
Transcendental Model Selection, A
Computational Account of Symbolic
Cognition and General Intelligence
Through Morality and Culture.
Hongju Pai reported on funds raised and
a variety of perspectives in some very
cool direction.
Going into ecosystem projects,
Arman Joe Cower
reported on active inference and
reinforcement learning in bandit
environments.
Kleber Gomes
had several blog posts.
One was from simulation to embodiment
towards artificial motivation,
curiosity, and fear.
Daniel Drummond reported a new
publication, Preventing a Civilizational
Collapse With the Help of the Free
Energy Principle.
David Frumni reported publication,
Relativistic Active Inference in the
Physics of Lived Experience,
A Unified Synthesis
of Perceptual Fluctuation, Allostatic
Self-Efficacy,
and Predictive Dynamics.
Hamza Amahi,
Ahinda Yogaraja,
Rohan Andasamy,
reported on a project
pre-ictal
interoceptive dynamics
in functional neurological disorder.
Hamza Amahi
reported on
HRIT E3
hierarchical recursive integration
theory.
Two-dimensional active inference
framework for consciousness.
Arsalan Shah
and Satyaki Mitra
reported on
>> Recording in progress.
>> their project
Samay
Phil Robinson
reported on the project
measurement framework for cognitive
regulation, autonomic load, and system
stability.
Maria Svet
reported on the project Mindloom
research program
compensatory defensive speech as active
inference.
Sam Sennshaw
reported on giving a talk at MC0001
on machine consciousness and the doom
argument.
Apologies for that.
We know reported
a new publication in Nature
Communications active inference as a
model of collision avoidance in human
drivers.
And they wrote a blog about it.
On the reference driver
Zoltan
Juhasz
reported on teleodynamic steering demo
for generative models.
With Joel Dietz
he wrote a publication and code base.
A living meta-analysis architecture for
active inference version extraction in a
publications and offices boring.
I wrote several publications.
One was towards lean forward
formalization of the free energy
principle.
Another using that approach was policy
entanglement in active inference.
And on policy distillation as active
inference in finite variation normal.
[snorts]
Okay.
Um
a few slides mainly carried over from
the previous
quarter.
And we'll just look to the live chat if
there's any specific questions.
And we'll
um
see
if there's anything specific. So, taking
one minute here.
>> Okay.
Going to end it here.
Thank you. Hope this was useful.
So long, suckers.